just as you saw in succession the Empire
basically disappearing with the demise
of Logan Royal because I think he in his
heart too you remember that Betty says
early on in series four you are not
serious people
for I love you but you are not serious
people I think that spoke to everything
about Logan Roy they were only Rich
because he made them Rich they'd never
earned a penny under their own steam I
think in a way when Rupa murder goes to
the great Newsroom in the Sky What's
Left of the Murdoch Empire is already
gone none of the siblings is interested
in running British newspapers they're
not really interested in the Wall Street
Journal either James and Elizabeth are
embarrassed by Fox News they'll want rid
of that I think you already begin to see
the demise in the Empire the way you did
in succession that's where in real life
and uh drama fiction I do think come
together